at no point am i saying or doing
anything that i can't back
with a saying of allah's messenger i
might be eccentric attic i admit it you
know i'll be very controversial and i'll
say things to trigger people
but at the end of the day if someone
comes at me you know on a private chat
or publicly i can whack them over the
head with the quran in the sunnah
i used to be an imam don't don't mess
with me i really know my stuff more than
people think they
they think i'm just you know some
regular old ghetto dude or something
and i was an imam for years i get a lot
of study under my belt i i lived in
mecca and medina
i studied with the ulama i sat with them
you know not in a big way but i sat in
the roost in the circles with some of
them you know i got you know i got my
lessons so you know don't
yeah don't play with me
salaam alaikum ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the t3m
podcast it's your host fired rami
and angel and we're joined with a
special guest today
so abu american the man the myth the
legend
i can't see y'all infamous huh
the man of infamy um
was that on her
i can't see y'all bro just keep talking
i'm uh i'm gonna change locations
all right no worries yeah man
so start us off man what's your story
ooh i mean where do we start off i mean
what what what what story you want to
hear
all right let's let's i've got a lot of
troubles let's reverse engineer the
uh the life of our american so currently
you know
you're we don't need to know about your
age none of that just tell us where you
are in life what you kind of do
your family uh the people you surround
yourself with and then we can work back
from there
okay i mean well where i'm at i mean we
don't need to go over age or anything
but
uh i'm in my late 40s almost 50.
i'm living in germany american citizen
uh just working and chilling here
i run my own online uh relationship
consultancy
i have multiple wives it's based upon
that basically my experiences with like
multiple relationships
um uh for better or for worse you know
all the failures uh weren't entirely
failures because i learned lessons from
them and i transfer those lessons
uh into practical experience to help
others
make sure they don't make the same
mistakes so um
yeah i mean that's just i mean really in
a basic nutshell that's where it is i
currently have three wives nine children
um just
you know work crypto and relationship
stuff that's about it
it's not really you know it's not a
spectacular or complicated story i'm
pretty actually you know straightforward
and simple guy
um okay so when you think about
something like this someone like this
inherently you think of someone that
okay he has you know three wives nine
children
um he's a muslim he he practices islam
to the best of his abilities till today
he's probably been raised like this
this is probably has already been him
since time but that's not really the
case here is it
no no no this is something i kind of i
kind of grew into
i mean i wasn't always muslim i became
muslim back in 98 and i've always had
i mean even prior to islam i had i had
like uh
i had a we'll just call it a love for
women i think all men have this
uh but some men have a stronger love
than other men
and some men exercise that uh stronger
than others so i mean in terms of
picking your poison as a man i kind of
pick mine early on
even prior to islam uh so
um yeah uh no wasn't always muslim
became muslim back in 98 uh when i was
with the u.s military
and uh i actually i remained monogamous
once i became muslim for 16 years so i
was
monogamously married i was together with
my ex-wife for like 26 years but 16 of
those years
was monogamously um and then i just
couldn't do it anymore you know i felt
it was having a negative effect on me in
terms of like my gaze and lowering my
gaze and whatnot and so i just went
ahead and did what was permissible to me
we just got married again which started
me on the current journey that people
know
of as the you know [ __ ] american
story funny
[Music]
i know yo i got a house bro is that a
green screen or you're in the woods
it's a it's definitely not a green
screen
um nice that's probably and you can see
us well now right
yeah i can see y'all though the wi-fi is
real nice
crispy perfect rummy you've been awfully
quiet
yeah man i'm just he's thinking yeah i'm
just i'm just listening man you can't
listen if you're talking
he's thinking about the several wives
all right so you said you reverted to
some in 98
yeah tell us a little bit two-part
question first about
the first bit of your life until 98 what
your views were in religion
theism as a whole your upbringing and
then the second part
get a little bit about what happened in
98 um
well i grew up in a military family
um we're generational military people
every generation tends to serve in the
military in my family
uh like my sons are now um so
i grew up uh predominantly in germany
you know son of an air force uh
ejection seed specialist on f4s back
when those things were still in service
they've been retired now not that that's
an important point but
just talking about it and um my mother
uh was pretty strong roman catholic
and so i grew up with a very strong
sense of belief
i think most african-americans when you
look at most african-americans were kind
of like very spiritual people anyway
um so yeah
i i was trying to find my place
basically
because we didn't go to church or
anything like this i was trying to find
my place in terms of like being uh what
i consider to be
you know a person who believes in god
and i went to several different
denominations baptist this that the
other you know trying to find my place
and i just found nothing but
disillusionment with like you know the
christian faith and
beliefs the contradictions and all sorts
of things
that's a very very long story that's not
like you know a two or three year period
that's like a very long period 10 plus
years
until eventually i was just like you
know screw it it's like you know i'm not
gonna
i've never said i was gonna be atheist
or agnostic or whatever else but i just
said i'm just gonna believe in god
and i'm gonna you know try and figure it
out
uh the gulf war came along and a lot of
homies got sent to
saudi arabia and one of them was like
that he was
this homie of mine named thomas and he
we went to high school together
and then uh you know military and
everything and so when he came back from
deployment from saudi he said he was
muslim
and i was just like complete completely
shocked i was like yo
you know you're white how can you be
muslim because
you're ignorant when you don't know
about islam i mean i think people are
more queued in nowadays because it's
just you know
islam and muslims have hit the spotlight
but back then i was like you know only
muslim
the only people that could be muslim
were like brown people and arabs i'm
like so what are you talking about
you're a white boy
you know and you come a long time about
your muslims it's impossible
but uh he's like no no it's not an
ethnicity you know it's a religion
so i i understood at that point that i
didn't understand islam
and so i listened to him because he was
also a homie you know and he was never
like an unreasonable person we got along
very well
and uh whatever everything he was
kicking everything he was saying was
like wow hey man
it's pretty deep and my understanding of
islam was already faulted you know from
my father loved him to death but you
know just completely
wholly ignorant on his thumb said all
sorts of crazy stuff
that you know isn't entirely untrue
probably information he got that was bad
and so now the entire understanding and
world view of like what islam was and
wasn't was like kind of like just
removed
and so um yeah i started attending juma
and everything and uh praying with them
and fasting
i did this for like three years i
basically believed in islam for like
three years but i never took my shahada
but you know speaking to some of the
ulama and saudi when i lived there
because i used to live in saudi
well they were like you know you
believed in the shahada thing you prayed
you fast
you made all the intentions of islam
it's like so you were you were muslim
but just to
cross the t's and dot the eyes i took my
shahada you know
and uh in 98 so uh yeah
that was uh that was the lead up to 98
in terms of belief and you know
life and whatnot just living and working
in you know in germany
the story is of course a lot deeper than
that i say it all the time but i tell
people my life story
they think i was lying so i'm not going
to go into a whole bunch of details but
yeah just living life in germany you
know black guy in germany it's like it's
basically like
i think they would say heaven on earth i
would be live but you know what i'm
saying i mean
you're the flavored week out here as a
man of color so i was just living it up
out here with women
you know partying whatever else until i
became muslim
um yeah and then that that basically led
into 98 basically
post 98 i became muslim started living
you know uh
living as a muslim you went full in you
know i'm little i still do
um and yeah i just i kind of flipped my
life
you know on its head 180 degrees you
know
right there in my own environment which
was actually quite tough you know
i mean it kind of shows you the wisdom
of the hadith of the man who killed 99
men
you know about leaving one environment
to go to a better one although i didn't
have
you know that man's problems um it was
very difficult
because i would have like
how do you say this for lack of a better
term
excuse me i had the old hoes coming up
you know oh hey
you know what's up what's going on and
i'm like here i'm like a muslim now you
know
hold up homie but that nobody around me
you know really understood you know the
change in the transition i gone through
except for some of the dudes that i used
to hang out with a lot of the guys i
used to hang out with it turns out we're
actually muslim
but we were clubbing together you know
and doing all sorts of crazy stuff and
running women so
they understood but uh you know a lot of
the women in the environment that i
lived in didn't so i just basically
i became beholden to
staying in the house i still do it to
this day you know i just kind of avoid
the streets just
not that i think i'm gonna run into
women it just became a habit you know
just staying out of trouble
so yeah post 98 that's basically been my
life up until
today um
okay man that's man that's i understand
now what you mean that
we'd probably be here for hours if you
really went in depth with everything
bro i got like a heck of a long story i
left out
i'm giving you cliff notes and i mean
with the cliff notes man we can go on
for quite
quite some time you know
i was kind of fascinated when i figured
out your ethnicity or like at least a
split like i had no idea about your mom
and
her parents and all that it's kind of
fascinating i thought you were 100
african-american
no no no no no no my mom's uh my mom is
mixed
uh so basically on my mom's side
my grandmother is 100 indian you know
like uh
like southeast asian indian so like they
see indiana like yeah
like daisy indian no indian
and her husband uh my grandfather is 100
white scottish he was a sailor and he
was stationed at the port of spain
which you know trinidad used to be a
commonwealth country of the united
kingdom
and so he was stationed there uh and
they met
and then there's my mom you know my dad
is a 100
african-american so yeah i'm i'm
mixed up yeah mm-hmm yeah okay so you're
50
50 african-american 25 scottish
25 indian you know what type of indie
do you know what type of indian your mom
was no no i don't know
i never really got into it never really
you know i could probably ask her
i mean she's not you know i'm there
she's still alive i could probably ask
her about it
it's never occurred to me to do it you
know god you got you
any siblings yeah yeah i have uh
two sisters and two brothers yeah uh i
used to be the youngest until my latest
sister was born
she's like she's gonna be about 14
now yeah i haven't met her unfortunately
you know um
it's from a relationship my father had
you know after my parents separated
you know so yeah but but i i've met her
online
i haven't met her in face-to-face you
know i better online
i talk to her regularly you know so yeah
are you close to the other siblings too
sorry are you close with your other
siblings as well
my brother my brother my the brother
closest to me
yeah um we we actually
i mean we're close again let me put it
like that there was a time when we felt
we had like falling out but generally
like we're close again
he married a feminist and then he
started calling himself a male feminist
and i just man i hate them leftists
you know hey
how does that work yeah i don't know
either man but you know most
african-americans like you know on the
liberal side and so
my brother was no different especially
after marrying a feminist and we just
had a lot of arguments ideological
arguments you know so um
we kind of drifted apart but then i kind
of called it you know
you know i love my i ain't crapping on
him you know it's an unfortunate
situation but he got a divorce like i
called it you know because
relationships with feminists never work
and so uh
when he separated we kind of like
drifted back together humbly a lot so
you know we we talk regularly now
again before it was just like it was a
mess when she was around
i just yeah
so yo if the two of you have anything to
just stay in just like hop in
whenever um but i just had a quick
question before we go on
only the top three places that you've
ever lived in and if you currently live
in one of them you can also see it
no again so of the top three places i
lived in what
your favorite three places of all time
to live oh okay
whatever top three places first and
foremost would be
saudi arabia i lived in medina medina
manual or medina sorry
uh for quite some time uh i i used to
teach there
in you know the city of
prophecy medina that would be the first
or else second i'd have to say
actually germany germany i mean i'm just
only because i spent the most time here
and so i'm most familiar with the place
and then after that the uk and
i just say the uk because the ease of
living there not because it's like some
fantastic place germany is not a
fantastic place either i just know it
very well
so i'm comfortable here and the uk is
similar
but it's easy to live there you know
they don't really complicate your life
there
once you have residency and all this
stuff man it's just like it's real easy
to live there and do your thing
so i'd say those two places but those
are not the top places i mean except for
medina that i've visited
in terms of because i've been to 46
countries i've traveled to 46 countries
and i lived in six
so oh no way yeah yeah bro i had no idea
about that
really okay in terms of in terms of uh
qatar you didn't even think of bringing
it up no no
um my experience there in terms of qatar
was quite rough
uh some nice people there some horrible
people there i even had like a qatari
brother reach out to me like two days
ago and invite me back over there said
totally on him you know i was like nah
bro i'm like man just off my heart bro
he's like hey man take these tickets in
this hotel come over here and stay i'm
just like nah i'm gonna have to pass on
me
that's how that's how rough my stay was
there you know and and
and that's literally an uh a reflection
of the entire country it's like you know
you're gonna have people that are really
good and you're gonna have people that
you you want to choke to death you know
and stare
in the eye when you do it you know so
it's just
there's no in between there's no like
middle ground you you just love hate you
know
and so uh um yeah so is that ptsd or you
want to get into that a bit
i mean you could probably call it ptsd
but you know i mean i think it's just
basic human nature that when you have
like a bad experience with something
a food a place you know an object you
know a particular car or something
you just don't want to deal with it
again you just don't want to mess with
it
like you know when we talk in terms of
psychology because i spent a lot of time
in psychology and i was talking about
i was reading something about um
negative conditioning
sort of like you know negative
reinforcement and this guy
when he was uh when he was in his mid
teens he was walking outside over some
ice and the ice was crunching
and then he slipped and he fell and he
like broke his hip in his leg
you know so you can imagine how hard he
felt as a team to actually break your
hip and your leg
and so basically every time he hears
that noise even if he's not the one
walking over it
he has like an extreme panic attack you
know
it's just is it reasonable probably not
but it's just like the human nature so i
mean you know 100
i'm not suffering like him but it's just
like you know when someone says nah man
i'm good bro
i'm straight you know it's just kind of
like this is an
automatic like just no you know
yeah i'm good um
in terms of the 46 countries you've
traveled to and you touch base on
what would be some that you can name
that you felt
the environment made it easy for you to
strengthen your iman or just practice
islam
saudi obviously even qatar obviously
uae kuwait is probably
at the the second on that list after
saudi arabia
um in terms of practicing the dean
yeah in terms of practicing they're all
gulf countries so yeah
those are the best mm-hmm have you been
to iceland
excuse me have you been to iceland no i
haven't been to iceland
i'd like to check that out though it
looks really nice but i've just never
yeah yeah it's so difficult getting out
there man have you seen like what it
takes to get out there dude just like
some crazy flights or boats i'm just
like yo
what the man is cold i just you know
what i mean i'm like we black people man
we're people of color it's like
we're not really cold weather people so
it's like if i'm gonna struggle to go
through a hardship to get out there and
then i'm gonna get out there and be cold
i'm gonna be kind of like hey man
i paid all this money and went through
all those like crazy trips and
for this you know i'd be kind of upset
i'm gonna be honest with you bro i have
no idea what you're talking about
because me and angel
went there with one flight it was hella
easy and for a brother that never spent
his life
outside of uh you know he's from puerto
rico florida
that's where he lives now it's warm and
he wasn't that cold so we had we had a
pretty decent experience with it
hold up hold up now bro don't don't be
trying to like
skew the story bro i did cold
conditioning
exercises before iceland to be ready for
trying to set me up bro you had no
winter jacket bro i think you were fine
he did cold conditioning though i ain't
doing me no cold conditioning i got
like this clothes ice baths okay
nasty night yeah like bro
here freezing and it's got like a
battery inside of it and it keeps me
warm it's like a heated vest i'll be
sweating
in that thing so i ain't trying to mess
with no cold conditioning no ice bath
like i'm some russian or something you
know
this man yo so if you don't like the
cold that much
why why would you live in the like i
understand you love germany and all that
stuff but like
wouldn't it be wouldn't it be more
logical to like find a place that's more
tropical
well yeah i mean i can't say i'm staying
in germany i mean right now it's peak
winter and it's like negative one
outside that's really
not that bad you know um it's still cold
but you know i'm i'm
i mean even even at 48 and i'm not
really trying to stay here i'm here for
my kids and
you know they're good they're growing up
i'd give it like four or five more years
and i'm trying to do my final move
somewhere man
this isn't this isn't it it's just too
difficult in general because it's a
socialist country and socialist
countries have too much taxes
if you're a hard worker they punish you
you know and if you're a bum
you get rewarded and so this is not a
place for like you know people who work
hard and who are industrious or
entrepreneurial they're just gonna tax
you to death so you can take care of
some
some you know excuse me some wanker
who's just chilling at a cafe all day
day you know surfing the internet on his
phone and harassing women that's because
that's what they do
so i you know i ain't trying to support
that man that's what they do out here
man this is a mess bro
that's how it is
yeah man it's crazy dude
and they got a hate affair with muslims
also i mean they
as many of them as there are here they
don't really like us
you know and why you want to stay away
somewhere where people don't really like
you you know what i mean
it's not that just food you know
yeah that is very true
all right bro all right masha'allah i
don't want to
like skip ahead in the story but
so i feel like a lot of people who are
watching and me myself obviously i need
to speak for myself
i feel like we're wondering what was the
transition like from being completely
monogamous because
we're all taught monogamy from a young
age because it's just what's
normal right and going against it isn't
just abnormal
but people actually think it's wrong so
when they hear about it in islam they're
like what the heck
so what was the transition like from
plague from polygyny polygamy to
or sorry for monogamy to polygyny
for me it was pretty natural i mean even
prior to islam
um before i became muslim i was
politicist
and my ex-wife she she kind of accepted
it as long as i didn't like going to
long-term relationships with these you
know
women and i kept them like constantly in
rotation she didn't really
care you know i mean she did but she
didn't you know as long as i didn't make
her look bad with it which i did a lot
of times
you know but as long as it didn't like
you know embarrass her you know or i
just like flaunt it right in her face it
was just like yeah okay
you know i got a good looking guy you
know he's doing okay and everything and
like you know women want them
um then going monogamous i actually
found that quite difficult that i pulled
it off 16 years i
got for the life of me i don't know how
guys do it you know what i mean um
i mean buttercloth fee can hum did a lot
to the guys who can you know i mean
i don't think there's anything wrong
with it if that's the choice you want to
make but i don't find it to be
you know from my perspective and the
perspective that i see from a lot of men
to be their natural disposition as men
um i think we have a natural you know uh
when i speak of
nature i mean like the nature that allah
put into men not
nature in the shirky sense uh i find it
to be that men actually have a
proclivity to like women you know
in general not just one and he's also
given us that capability and capacity to
love more than one woman and to love
more than one woman deeply as opposed to
women
who because of the way that allah
designed them
love an individual man deeply
so for me that transition very natural
uh what was difficult was now the status
quo for my ex-wife was
i've been with him monogamously for like
all these years
and now all of a sudden he's throwing a
whole wife up in the mix from one day to
the next you know and not only did i
throw one in i just went out
and i was just like da i go crazy and i
grab two right off the rip you know i
just
when i married two women immediately um
so uh you know for her that was like a
huge shock and it was a huge transition
it was
very very tough the two new women it
wasn't so bad because
i could pro not program but for lack of
a better term i could program them and
give them the concept and understanding
that hey
you know this is this is this is the
program right now multiple women and you
are going to be on that team or you can
just go ahead and walk your business and
go
about your business right now so
in that sense for me easy her
less so and this is something that i
tell guys a lot nowadays when i do
consultations when i do my videos is
like you know this is something you have
to discuss with your girl
your woman your wife very early on in
the marriage
uh preferably prior to marriage you know
um because
if you try and change from no discussion
of polygamy
you know to polygamy mid game
it's just going to blow up in your face
i've only seen it work twice
you know and even then when it worked it
was rough you know
so yeah so let me ask you something bro
yeah do you think that dudes who
are settling and i'm gonna use that word
specifically
all right so bear with me so you think
dudes who are settling for monogamy they
are
making excuses
that's the question i'm just making sure
before okay
if that's the entirety of a question um
that's hard to speculate i mean
that's like saying you know i mean it's
kind of hard to you know
it's like the messenger of a lot of
people said you can't tear open the
hearts of people and see the intentions
inside of it
but a lot a lot of the times what i do
see especially the more
uh vociferous a man is in terms of
anti-pelligent the more he wants it
there's
just no way a person who's happy doesn't
complain
about stuff that like doesn't affect or
change his life i've never seen it you
know
it's like when a monogamous guy
monogamous guys don't bother me
you know what i mean i'm i'm polygenist
and i stay religious you don't see me
attacking guys who are monogamous you
know because i'm happy polygenist
so it's the same thing in reverse and i
know a lot of monogamous guys they
they're not bothered by pelogeny
so a lot of times what you do find is
that those guys who are most
anti-polygeny are the ones who are
the ones who want it the most and so
they attack it
what do they say you know despise what
you can't have
this is this is the this is the basic
mentality so a lot of guys are in denial
about their situation and they're not
trying to convince you they're trying to
convince themselves
they're trying to convince their wife
because they're an insecure and in
unstable footing with their woman and so
they also constantly
think or believe that this is going to
placate her
and make her more endeared to him when
the opposite is true
the more masculine traits you show the
higher value you show
the more that women want you the more
she's gonna want you
because women operate off social proof
it's like gucci handbags and liberal
teeny shoes
oh if she wants it then i want it oh if
she doesn't want it why would i want it
and that applies to you as a man also
so there's a funny meme out there it's
not a muslim one it's
obviously but they're you know this
woman says it's a meme and she says
you know i'm glad my man doesn't have
any hoes but why doesn't he have hoes
am i fighting for a position that nobody
wants so
understand the way that women think they
operate off social proof
if there aren't women clamoring over
themselves to get you
eventually she's gonna start having
doubts and the more you fight that idea
that
i don't want other women this that the
other she's gonna sit there and be
looking like
i just got this this this guy that
nobody wants
why am i here and so it's a mistake to
even act like
it's not a possibility for you even if
you don't want to be politicized
at least act like you could be you know
that doesn't mean acting like you want
to be but act like you could be
because that makes you attractive but
you know you sitting out here you're
dealing with guys who nowadays you know
they're dealing with and i don't want to
be insulting or offensive but the
reality is you're dealing with less than
normal testosterone levels
and so their their their their drive and
desire for women is probably lower than
normal
and so some of these guys are quite
happy other guys you know
they're going to be like like me you
know
i'm not blowing my own horde it's just i
in my circle
i tend to keep guys that have a
particular mentality behavior
and mindset and um i couldn't look at
any of these guys and say they're low t
you know or like you know they're soft
or something like this you know
or their their entire world of like you
know is like trying to placate their
woman
and that's not to say that you don't try
and make your girl happy that's not what
i'm saying at all but
you know what i'm saying yeah i get it i
get it
they are their own mental point of
origin you know
and so they don't make her the mental
point of origin because that's needy and
guys who are you know masculine and
about masculinity they are not
needy you know yeah and that's the thing
man like i see that a lot
where i will see a dude who will say
right he will verbally say that he is
happy
and like he's content with it but it's
like i could see it in his eyes and his
body language whenever he's around
other women and like bro how much you
want to
how much you want to bet that they're uh
watching pornography and i hate to say
that here because like obviously we're
trying to keep things alive but
dude like how many dudes especially
those who aren't muslim
who they say that they're happy with
their woman yet they're here watching
pornography they're here looking at all
these
other women it's like come on bro don't
lie to yourself don't lie to yourself
you made a solid point from from my
consultations one thing that i do is i
talk to a lot of guys and a lot of guys
have pornography addictions and
i've never met never met a guy that was
college
that had a pornography addiction not one
you know but they've always been
monogamous guys
and i had this conversation with my
newest wife recently you know and we
were talking
i was like i was like look i said look
at any guy who's
who's monogamous and guys forgive me out
there if you're watching this you're
monogamous
don't be women don't don't don't act
like women to the guys watching this
women we expect to react to words
don't think about how words make you
feel
listen to the words and the logic and
reason and this is another problem that
we have with men today
they look at words and they listen to
words and
they react like women how does that make
me feel then you get angry
but logic and reason guys so here's the
thing
if you look at most monogamous men you
find that there is some sort of
extreme behavior that they partake in to
compensate for lack of what they really
want which is which is normally another
woman
you'll find those overweight guys
they're eating themselves
you know they're eating themselves into
satisfaction
you know they're video gaming themselves
into satisfaction instead of going out
and getting the woman they want
they're i mean i go to the gym but you
find guys are excessive in going to the
gym
and trying to like compensate for not
getting what they want you will find
some sort of extreme behavior in most
monogamous men
guys who are politicists they tend to
not all but they tend to have a very
good balance in terms of
what they're doing and you know and
going to extremes and excessiveness
it's because they're getting what they
want and so they're satisfied with life
and so they don't go into extremes in
eating they don't go to extremes in
lifting or video games or this or that
they tend to be more moderate in
everything that they do
except obviously women so
that's the extreme but that's normal and
natural because if it wasn't
it wouldn't be something that was made
permissible by alana's messenger
so boom that's my that's my take
thanks thanks and even all the other
prophets pc from
all of them well a lot of them had
multiple wives some of them were
monogamous but a lot of them had
multiple wires
as they broke i had my best friends
interrupting you there but i had
a lot of christian friends back in the
day and like
yeah i had one girl but it's like i
still understood
like my internal male nature that like i
wanted to be with more than one woman
and bro like i would talk to them about
it they're like no that's not right
that's not right and i'm like dude like
in the bible
there's even reports of people having
multiple wives like how can you guys be
against that
i mean monogamy is actually a pretty rel
is a relatively
new creation in terms of western society
i mean the romans were the ones who
basically brought it in
but the romans actually you know even
though the romans brought in monogamy
the romans were okay
with concubines and prostitution so it
was normal for a man to be married
only to one woman but to actually have
concubines mistresses
and visit prostitutes it wasn't seen as
like a negative thing in their society
and culture and this is what a lot of
people like to overlook and they fail to
understand
[Music]
you know what we're doing as much as
we're literally
emulating the non-muslims
you know in their behaviors and the
prophet peace be upon him said it and
it's amazing that we're even having this
conversation i mean think about how
amazing that is
when the mission of peace be upon him
said you are going to emulate you're
going to
be the non-believers hand span by
handspan to the point that if one of
them
you would find people from amongst the
muslims to do it all and here we are
nobody ever stopped to think for
instance
we are due
to monogamy nobody ever stopped your
your connection just keeps going in and
out with the awesome yeah i thought it
was just me so i didn't say anything but
oh yeah yeah you know michael is really
bad
you're spitting some facts right now so
it's like it's
it's a little rough that it's doing this
right now oh
that's unfortunate
yeah maybe i should hot spot over my
phone my phone generally has been
my house let me yeah you were telling us
something that's happening in your house
and then you just went back to that so
we couldn't even hear that last part
um one second i might drop i'll be right
back
give me a second
all right in the meantime inshallah one
thing i wanted to say was that
i feel like a lot of men like i said
they're conditioned by society this is a
given right they're conditioned to think
that monogamy is the only way polygyny
is like there's no such thing
and as abu mentioned but they're you
know watching porn and hill mentioned as
well they're watching porn they're doing
this doing that checking other women
the other even like uh side chicks and
prostitutes and all this stuff on the
side
um so they know they're pollutionists in
nature but they're monogamous mentally
and this is an issue because it creates
a cognitive dissonant
like uh effect in which they're
acting one way they're saying something
else
and they don't even know where they
stand internally and this could manifest
itself in many ways
for me i would say it manifested in
terms of neediness because
looking back i could have put i'll just
call my energy
into multiple women and it would have
been fine but i tried putting all of it
into one and i had so much i'll just
call it
loving energy that's all i'll say i was
putting it all into one place and then
it became
overburdening and then it became needy
and then it became
she's no longer here she was there but
she wasn't really
there anymore you know what i mean and
that was the beginning of the end i'd
say
led me to a new beginning but that's
what it manifested
itself as for me just that neediness and
like abu mentir manifest itself in many
different ways but this is the issue
because men can be monogamous man can
this is why monogamy is halal
he says if you can't be just then marry
one
it's halal as well the prophet saw he
was married to hadith
for over a decade and he was monogamous
to her but after she
this is what i wanted to mention i
mentioned it earlier after she passed
away
then he started pulligeny and it's kind
of like i feel like i can relate to him
in the sense that
once he got his heart broken because it
was heartbreaking for him once he got
his heart broken
now he's open to polygyny that first
initial love that every guy has
once that's broken it's not the same
anymore that's what it was like
once it was broken it was never the same
but now i'm open to polygyny it's like a
bit it's almost like
it's almost like you took the red person
yeah that's all i said i'm subhan allah
i i just i think that's profound but abu
have you uh hot spotted
yeah yeah i hope so uh i'm on my phone
right now that should be better
so much better i could tell it's a
little a little clearer bro
i could see the uh pores on your face
now
nice so
you made one last comment um all i
remember from it was polygony
um wow nice bro
nice bro i had it in my head until i
started talking then i forgot it
hello wow i missed a lot
yeah bro oh man i was on a roll there
so bro you were talking about you were
talking about the men
and how like the uh the addictions and
how like they'll go from one
extreme to the other and then how the
romans were the ones that brought
monogamy
but they were cool with like the um the
whorehouses concubines
okay yeah yeah so recapping basically
it's like um
recapping what i was saying is like you
find that usually you know monogamous
men tend to have like some sort of
extreme behavior
um that manifests itself for a lack of
doing what they really want which is to
which is marrying and making love to
multiple women
i mean it's not being vulgar or anything
to say that you know
we make love to women and as long as
it's in a permissible way
this is what a lot of guys want to do oh
but in in lieu of that what they end up
doing is they end up making love to to
the food they become excessive in gym
they become excessive in video games
sometimes these meditation
manifestations
can be positive obviously especially
when you talk about like going to the
gym
making money but they tend to be like
very very top-heavy
in those particular areas to the point
that they nearly neglect the marriage
that they have you know um they become
excessive in it or it makes them
unattractive
like some guys they'll just start eating
themselves you know i know a brother
he he's very nice brother i met him
qatar
and he wanted to get married very badly
to another another woman
and because he couldn't he just was
eating and eating eating and he was
literally like 90 kilos over his body
weight
and every time we had this conversation
he would get he would get
i noticed he got depressed and he'd
start eating you know let's go
let's go you know here let's go there
let's go there there's always a
restaurant and i'm just like man bro you
can't be doing this to yourself
and his wife literally like had him
under her thumb she's like really just
running them you know and he was
he was successful he was making good
money he he basically had the position
to do what he wanted to do
and prior to this he was he was like a
college football player the guy was like
quote unquote alpha and then he just let
himself go because he couldn't get what
he wanted because he wanted
you know to be mr booby boo i love you
to you know to his girl
and that's not that's not that's not
what she wants from you
but that's what he gave her uh in terms
of monogamy what i was saying was
monogamy is relatively new in the west
and it was the romans who brought it in
but the romans were people who
were not really entirely monogamous they
had prostitutes concubines and
mistresses
so it was acceptable for a man to be
married and then to have mistresses or
concubines or prostitutes
that was completely considered
acceptable now in terms of the western
society and what we want to see is
muslims okay
we're pleased that they gave up all of
this stuff because prostitution haram
you know but
the reality is when they gave that up
you know they just kind of left men on
their own in terms of like you know
being you know
what they really wanted in western
society and we see it hasn't worked
because as we know pornography and
prostitution are still a thing
if not pornography it's more of a thing
than ever before
you know and it's obvious there is no
like just like there's age checks
on on pornography there's no marriage
checks it's obviously made for men
irrespective of his marital status you
know uh it's probably aimed at married
men more than it is
single men allahu ta'ala adam
but coming back to my point of emulating
the non-muslims
when we look at like what muslims are
doing nowadays
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
he said verily
you know some of you he's like you know
the muslims will
emulate the non-muslims they'll copy
copy them you know uh they're imitating
the non-muslims
handspan by handspan to the point that
if one of them entered into a lizard's
hole in another narration says that if
one of them
slept with their mother you'd find
muslims from amongst the muslims doing
it also
so now you find it i find it you know
very interesting that the muslims are
emulating the non-muslims in their
marriage practices of polygany
i mean of monogamy and they never once
you know missed a beat and thought to
themselves like you know hey we're
copying these people
to the point where like we find muslims
trying to forbid
and make haram polygeny you know so i
mean
it's just it's an immolation of
non-muslims because this was never
something that the messenger of a lot of
people when
peace be upon him did it that did you
know said you can't be married to
multiple women
the sahaba didn't do it the
rashid none of them ever said this
though
nobody has ever said it's impermissible
but you find a lot of muslims today
especially the women
saying that it's not permissible and so
this is just copying this is
the imitation of muslims in their ways
so i just find it mysterious that
nobody's ever
skipped you know thought for a second
like you know
hey this is part of that hadith it's
just amazing
you know this never occurred to anybody
obviously it goes into further than just
marriage
because uh like our brother was saying
you know monogamy is completely
permissible also
but it's it's it's permissibility is as
equal as polygamy
you know so it's like what are y'all
talking about you know
they're acting like monogamy is [ __ ]
like you have to yeah
yeah yeah it's not a lot bro let me
let me chime in here because you were
saying something that like
just sparked something but it just
reminded me of like when i was younger
and i had uh i got my first girlfriend
bro and it's like
in the beginning most men will start
with the masculine frame
they'll start in that alpha state
because bro it's enough it's in our
nature
and once we do get with the woman it's
like
it's like you said if you start to
restrict yourself like
something's gonna give you're gonna
buckle somewhere you're gonna have an
extreme somewhere or you're just gonna
let yourself go
and it's like ramy was saying he started
getting needy
bro like i remember i was getting needy
certain times i remember i was uh
i would stop working out and i just
started like seeing myself in like a
lesser light
and it's like dude i don't know if you
guys know this but there's this
um mma fighter his name is israel
adesanya
and he always says uh keep the same
energy
that you brought in like in the
beginning and like obviously he's
talking about fighting but
we can definitely refer back to this
where it's like all right you get a
woman
keep that same energy or else it's all
gonna go downhill
and this is crazy that you're saying
that like if if a man is restricting
himself
which that is what's happening nowadays
and you know not to say that okay
every man needs to be politionist
because that that might not be the best
move
you know some men actually do want to be
with one woman that's cool but it's like
all right if
if you are a man and you do want to be
with multiple women like
do not restrict yourself
yeah you know there's science behind
this actually
and i mean you can anybody can google
this
basically the monogamous relationship
his testosterone levels naturally drop
and this is uh by the wisdom of the law
to like you know
make the man want to stick to the
relationship with the woman
so then like you know follow his or
you know purposeful nature if that's
what we want to call it
um you know the male reproductive
strategy is spread and prey you know
impregnate as many women as possible and
women
uh they generally are the opposite
because you know
they have to care for young and women
can only have someone young at one time
you know they have to pick very
carefully when it comes down to males
and uh his ability to provision and care
for and protect those children
so she's very intensely focused on
finding the best possible male
and focusing on him and keeping him
happy and sticking around
so um it makes sense that men actually
like you know start acting like this
once they get to him
you know into a relationship now this
doesn't stand true for men
obviously who are in a relationship with
multiple women his testosterone levels
increase
and they you know they get higher
because he's dealing with multiple women
which is more of
in line with his reproductive strategy
as opposed to monogamy
so it makes sense that you know that
takes place
i mean i saw it myself i mean you know
it happened to me too
you know when i was being monogamous you
know you you become a different person
and it's not a person you're comfortable
with my wife says it on twitter if you
follow me on twitter you'll see my wife
says that she's
and she said i hate that i love it that
he's at his best
when there's
[Music]
but i'm at my best when there's more
woman involved i really am it makes me
better
you know because when you have multiple
women involved and when you're involved
with multiple women in a relationship
it's not forgiving they look at you
closely
because you're doing something that that
they really don't want
they're willing to do but they really
don't want and so when you screw up
they're gonna be on you about it and so
you have to
as a man be on your absolute a game at
all times in all things because they are
sitting there waiting for you to screw
up
it just makes you better you know i like
the challenge i'm a man i like a
challenge i like
like push myself you know and it's not
just because of that that i you know i
have multiple women but it just makes me
better it forces me to be better
you know it forces me to like you know i
get up in the morning and i have to like
you know what
i gotta be the emotional rock for
multiple people
they look to me for answers they look
for me to decisions you know they look
for me to they look to me for leadership
you know
i don't have any of these boss chicks
and all that crazy stuff you know
no that's my job and they look to me for
that you know
and so i have to at all times be at the
top of my game and i
freaking love it man because otherwise
you're going to drift through society in
life just being average
who wants that no guy wants that this is
one of the things
this is what guys are looking for in
video games tell me it's not true
when you're getting a video game you
want the strongest character you want
the best equipment you want you know the
highest level
because you want to kick rear in the
game well he's kicking rear in the game
because he can't do it in real life
the only way you're going to kick for
your life is being the best that you can
in life
and let me tell you something you got
multiple women staring at you and
jumping on you for stuff
and i mean my woman don't jump on me but
but you know what i'm saying but if you
if you're like just if you have to
perform
you're going to be the top of your game
you know you're going to be the top of
your game
that's my take i've offered one with
this question
yeah you think who's going to disagree
with you there's a lot of people who
disagree with me just because i said it
oh yeah all the monogamous men maybe
yeah but
oh yeah for sure for sure yeah but um i
was gonna ask so
a lot of people i think i think are
gonna take in a negative light like you
know you're being forced to act in a
certain way
i want to ask does it make you feel good
right does it produce a good feeling
and is it a good kind of push that you
have is it like is it rewarding in a
sense
because with me just like rewarding it
is right okay just
because with me it's like i'm working
for my family alhamdulillah but none of
them are a wife
right they're like my sister my brother
my mother not even kids
right not even my kids so it's i don't
see in the same light and i'm just i'm
thinking to myself
if i had if we just added a wife to the
equation
it would be a thousand times more
rewarding just working and making money
and providing and all this stuff
but since that's not there it's not as
rewarding but the force in the drive is
still there
so i want to know if there's a
differentiation between being forced in
a negative light or being forced in like
a rewarding light
yeah there is obviously um the force is
self-imposed
you know i can just i can cruise control
it i mean and
i'm not bragging but at the same time i
kind of am
when i say i'm a good looking guy i'm
fit you know i take care of myself
i make a steady decent income online you
know
i i i'm pretty good in my in my category
of man
you know you compare me to guys half my
age i go to boxing i go jiu jitsu and
all this stuff i'm beating up guys who
are 25 they should be at the top of the
game whipping
old man around the ring and i'm smoking
dudes you know unless they're the top of
the team
so they see this so um i could just
cruise control it
just being me but is that good enough
it's not good enough for me so for me
i need that challenge and if there's no
pressure i'm not going to push myself
that's not how humans work
humans always look for the easiest path
of least resistance
ah man you know i need to push i need
that push and i like it
you know dude is it is it mandatory on
me no
they love the heck out of me my women
and that's not by accident that's you
know
that's researching vetting you know
checking these women
making sure they're the right type of
women so
that pressure is is 100 mine it's 100
internal and you know it helps
improve the relationship there's no way
you're gonna have a good relationship if
you're not the best
version of yourself for yourself
you know and so whatever it takes for
you as a man
to make you the best man that you're
going to be do it and i talk about this
i'm writing a guide to female submission
because i think everybody knows
you know i got my wives tie my shoes and
all this stuff and people freaking out
about it
but you know i have very very very very
submissive women
and it's not degrading to them contrary
to popular belief this submission and
when i speak as female submission to a
man
it's not something that is degrading to
them this is not the intention or
purpose whatsoever
um but uh it's more of like the natural
order and state of things
and so if you if you need that if you
want that when i'm writing my submission
guide
i talk about this all the time it's kind
of like the if you build it and they
will come
and it's the same mentality you're
building the best version of you
for you and everything that comes as a
reward for this
you go to school if you're a student and
you get good grades and you get the best
possible job
you did that for what so you could get
the best possible job and the best
possible money
when you anything you do for a reward
you do
for yourself you don't do it for that
thing
when you when a person went to
university and he studied he didn't go
to university and study so that
you know uh for the purpose of mit
you're not sorry for for apple
he went for himself you know and then
the reward is working
wherever he wants to having the choice
to work where he wants to
as opposed to looking at it like oh
apple's going to pick me
if i if i just do this this is what guys
are doing in regards to women no
build yourself and you have your choice
then when you go out into the world and
you're like you know what
apple just wrote me a little but then
you know these guys over here just wrote
me a letter too
you have your options you have your
choices and it's the same thing with
women
women like high value men you know and
they are on the hunt for them
and so make yourself a high value man
and do whatever it takes to do that for
me this is what it takes for me
i i you know some people can say that's
bad oh you need women to make yourself
you know the best possible version of
you
this is my pressure and that pressure is
100 100
internal you have to imagine i got these
women i have multiple women i have three
wives
obviously i was doing this prior to them
showing up because if i hadn't been
doing that work
they wouldn't be here they'd be like
yeah you know who's this
you know lazy schlub bum over here you
know trying to chat me up talk about be
you know one of many wives of his
obviously this is
something i did on my own already so
it's the same thing when you get inside
that
relationship in that marriage for me it
becomes a greater push to continue
pushing even harder
not for another why it's just because i
like the results
you know um
but uh yeah you got romney's gear
spinning bro
look at you look at him
i'm just internalizing all this looks
like a kid in a candy store
uh craig i was gonna say that uh you
know as you're speaking it just reminds
me there's so many women i know that
they get into a relationship
with a man and they perceive that man is
high value and then over time they start
saying these things like
oh you don't have to go to the gym
anymore you don't have to do this you
don't have to like you know you're
already perfect i already want you for
who you are i already love you for who
you are and i'll never let you go
and like you know you don't need to keep
working out you know you can just eat
whatever it's just you know it's just
one
you know whatever and before you know it
this guy's no longer who he wants and
then she left him
because he did exactly what she told him
to do yeah that's a test
mm-hmm
you're kind of like your video is frozen
and uh well he's not even it anymore
he left the chat he disappeared dang
yo so let me just throw in here by the
time he's um coming back right
so there's a few type of women that are
probably going to watch this there's
there's one the first one is gonna be
the ones who
agree okay the second ones
are gonna be the ones who um well they
don't really agree
but it's like they just they don't want
that then you're gonna have the
feminists for like better words they're
gonna be like completely on
the opposite end but it's like yo you're
showing them the facts you're showing
them the logic
and at the end they're just gonna be
like oh well i just i would never do
that
there we go we got him back we got him
back welcome back sorry guys i don't
know what happened
i just literally just dropped i mean it
was the weirdest thing the signal no
worries man your connections are
like on time right now oh yeah um what
was it saying it's a trap
it's a test yeah man eight ten months
later now now they got a new guy
uh and it's just taking time bomb until
he just fulfills her desires and wishes
and
no longer striving for being the best
man he could be
um i'd like to make a point on this and
this for all the guys out there who are
monogamous and they're gonna remain
monogamous i don't you know i don't care
what you do just make sure your marriage
lasts
um monogamous or palligenous don't
listen to that stuff from women
listen she is
attracted to you if she wasn't
well she shouldn't married you first off
but generally there has to be some form
of attraction on her part to marry you
and here's the thing a lot of women say
things
that uh in the hopes that you will do
stuff that will make you
unattractive to other women but
the problem is she's a woman too and
remember social proof and i talked about
this earlier with social proof
if you become attractive to other
unattractive to other women
you become unattractive to her remember
if other women don't want you why should
she want you
no be attractive and stay attractive you
know you don't have to go to the gym i
know i don't have to go to the gym baby
but you know i'm going i'm gonna go hit
these weights
you know oh you don't have to do this
yeah i know but you know i'm gonna do it
i'm still loving you yeah i know but i
love myself and that's why i want to go
i'm going to the gym because i love
myself and i like to look a particular
way i look really good i like looking
good
so you know i'm going to go to the gym
on the lift i'ma do like this you
are your focus point you are the mental
point of origin for you
not her who cares if she doesn't think
you have to go to the gym
why would you listen to that i mean it's
not that you it's not that you hate your
woman or
you know you're disrespecting her but
it's like what kind of crazy statement
is that
if one of my girls said hey you ain't
gotta go to the gym and they've said it
before i be like i look at her like
she's crazy i'm like what are you
talking about i don't have to go to the
gym no
i don't have to go to the gym but you
know i'm going to the gym i went to the
gym before i met you why would i stop
now
because you're here really oh wow i'm
just going to stop
being me because you're here now oh my
allah baby you know and i use cocky
funny to to clown my girls with stuff
like this when they come with that goofy
stuff
you know i don't because it's not worth
arguing over but at the same time
it's a test and you can't fall for it
you know but at the same time you do
have to have a good response for it
because then you're
who are you trying to look good for well
everybody you know trying to look for
your
for your potential next wife you know
your co-wife he just joke with her you
know
this goes back to what i'm saying about
monogamous guys you know act like it's
something you can do even if you're not
going to do it be confident be calm be
cool about it
she's going to find it attractive
because of your confidence
but a lot of guys are counter-intuitive
oh if i say that she's gonna freak out
i'm gonna be sleeping on the sofa
well if you have that mentality i don't
know how you got married in the first
place you know but
you know what i mean it's like you know
guys fall for these tricks and these
traps from women man and it's just
i find it completely like like dude
are you serious you know this goes back
to what i'm saying about guys eating
them ways and you know their ways into
stuff or out of stuff you know we're
going to excessiveness
it's kind of long along the same lines
yeah
um we got a lot of young bucks in the
that are probably gonna be watching this
now
wondering because we have a lot of
viewers 15 16 uh even 12 13
and they're probably going to be
confused about all this but it's just
cognitive dissonance as romney says
wow okay essentially it's essentially
being brought up one way
experiencing knowing internally you want
something else not being able to admit
it
and then having it manifest itself into
your life regardless
yeah and yeah like like you mentioned it
it comes out in different manners and
this is the he's right he's right
yeah everyone's right like how do you
how do you go against
uh mental conditioning if you're not
mentally conditioning yourself
to reverse it you know what i mean you
would have to mentally condition
yourself to unwire everything that's
been wired your entire life but if
you're not cog if you're not
conscious of that if you're not aware of
that it's like it's like we always say
the biggest problem a person can have is
not knowing they have a problem
because then nothing gets done if you
know you have an issue at least you you
can try and work on it from there
yeah you know um one thing i'll tell a
lot of young guys and it's not going to
be easy especially for the young guys
um because of peer pressure social
pressure and whatnot you know
and peer groups everybody wants to have
their homies you got to be ready to be
the bad guy
you know if you want to be who you want
to be
and we're talking permissibly you have
to be prepared to be the bad guy
anything you want the more the more a
person practices islam the more you find
that he'll find people that
will oppose him from we're talking about
from amongst the muslims
you know oh you're one of those
extremists i'm a salafi people say i'm
some sort of extremist you know oh
you're one of those guys blah blah blah
isis you know and then they start saying
all sorts of goofy stuff but since when
it has been a bad thing to want to
practice islam
in a better way you know in a way closer
to the method of the messenger of allah
peace be upon him
if you're going to do what's right or do
what's good for you
in a permissible way people will hate
you for it
you know why because people are afraid
and they
hate to see you pursue what you want how
you want
and actually get it knowing that they
are incapable themselves
of doing it and that that that's that
is 100 internal people are angry
and they're upset and when you really
ask them why when you sit down and talk
to these people they can't tell you
and you know what that is that that's
the opposite side of that cognitive
dissonance
they can't accept that i'm angry
because i can't do what i want to do
they'll give you
all sorts of and trust me i spend a lot
of time with angry people online they
hate me
on muslim twitter and i spend a lot of
time having a lot of conversations with
these guys
and they can never entirely vocalize
what they have against me i had this
conversation
yesterday classic example i
i did a show with my wives you know they
were on the show in the
cob and all you could see was their eyes
and the person came on and started
talking about oh you got your wives
you're on the timeline just at the other
and you know
uh people hearing their voices and i
said whoa i said give me a hadith
give me an ayat give me an opinion from
the book of the sunnah that says the
woman's voice
is aura that it's it's part of her
private part you know that it's not
something that's supposed to be heard i
said drop that for me go ahead
and they kept on coming up oh with this
oh with that oh with this oh with that i
was like no no no i said i asked you for
a
lil proof that a woman's voice is not to
be heard
according to the quran and according to
the sunnah show me this
oh well are you saying you know well you
had them on the timeline i'm like yeah
and i said describe my wives to you i
said tell me their ethnicities
because people keep asking me what their
ethnicity is you can't even tell their
ethnicity because
all you can see is their eyes so this
person just kept on on and on well are
you saying
that if brothers came over your house
they'd all sit together i just blocked
them
because it's obvious they don't know
what they're mad about they just want
they're mad because i'm doing something
that they
can't personally comprehend or accept
that i can actually do
and it be permissible or that you know
it goes against their culture
and so before we proceed like we got a
lot of non-muslim peeps here so
in your own words just the term solution
what does that mean
salafi um salafi is a is a methodology
of islam
um it's a methodology of islam where the
salaf
were the companions of the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
and so when the and the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him he says you know the
people who are upon guidance
are those who follow me and myself you
know the right the goddess
who are the salaf and so we say we are
salafi we follow them
you know we followed the the prophet
muhammad according to the understanding
of the salaf
because it was the salaf who gave us and
translated and transmitted to us the
religion as we know it
so we say we're salafi because we follow
that it's an orthodox form of islam you
know
that follows uh yeah i just explained it
basically i'm just repeating myself ten
times
yeah so when i say i'm selfie muslim a
lot of people you know and there's a lot
of anger and hatred against
muslims because they're quite orthodox
and you know uh everything is you know
allah the saying of allah and the saying
of his messenger
you know and this is why a lot of people
hate me also because they come at me
with stuff that i say and i do
but at no point am i saying or doing
anything that i can't back
with a saying of allah's messenger i
might be eccentric addict i admit it you
know i'll be very controversial and i'll
say things to trigger people
but at the end of the day if someone
comes at me you know on a private chat
or publicly i can whack them over the
head with the quran in the sunnah
i used to be an imam don't don't mess
with me i really know my stuff more than
people think they
they think i'm just doing some regular
old ghetto dude or something
and i was at a man for years i get a lot
of study under my belt
i lived in mecca and medina i studied
with the ulama i sat with them you know
not in a big way but i sat in the roost
in the circles with some of them you
know
i got you know i got my lessons so you
know don't yeah don't don't play with me